all right so how did you get started
marine like with tidying up like this
whole thing is so I actually became very
interested in the art of tidying at the
age of five okay no kinky difficut day
my home to me and the kazoku no more no
more you know you look at doesn't get
democratic ironies and I was just very
interested in organizing things so I
would organize my family's items
secretly and I would get in trouble for
that yeah you got in trouble I would pay
my children to do to tidy out my
five-year-old never does that
KOMO if I teach Anthony even know Kazuki
Oh Jimmy rip tear go toyou okay can you
stack Iike my joke is another condo cut
advocate oh okay oh she got things to do
in your panties so after a lot of
research of course that was kind of part
of the process and at the age of 19
that's when I decided to turn this
organizational tithing thing into like
my business so how does being tidy help
in other areas of your life and who
didn't yo quiero Kodaka demonic cat
let's get it both of them out of this so
I feel like when you tidy something up
you're not just tidying up your house it
really kind of tidies up your mind and
your heart as well okay okay
mano y anymore Indian Conchita Perez
shigoto dr. iran Makoto in cast a
tsunami today Toki me come on over our
very own that day so through the tidying
up process it kind of teaches yourself
what sparks joy in you and then once you
kind of train this muscle you can apply
that to other areas of your life as well
oh my ma'am I need it so what's your
process of getting rid of things that's
it look you know but don't worry between
if they could add icing on this game or
something guys no no even the
multi-terminal make it cousin asked me
to table on this the most important
thing is to organize and tidy by
category in the first step in doing so
is you have to take all the items from
that category and collect them in a
single space team a good model different
guys how about you come over here and
eat the leaf so if you're gonna start
with clothes then get every single clove
our article of clothing in your house in
once
face and you grab it you touch it you
feel and you see if it sparks joy inside
of you is there anything you've had a
hard time letting go of get out of name
on the floor this knit I know the sugar
need to say anything I'm gonna a little
teeny bumper there t-shirt for that
there are like this so there's actually
a t-shirt that I purchased in 2005 a
long time ago that I just can't get rid
of it's so clean 2005 no stains I'd pin
[Laughter]
because me secretly repeat the semester
it's a little embarrassing and I can't
explain why but it just sparked so much
joy inside of me this is the first time
that I'm showing it on TV you know it's
part join me if I could finish shirt I
bought in college that is a Bacardi Rum
shirt that I found in a thrift store and
it says I'm rich smooth and flavorful
I've had it for 20 plus years and I am
happy every time I see it that's for me
and it's not even mine yeah especially
your kid hold up a Bacardi shirt also
let's note in the absence of joy in my
son's face like fine it's sparking
nothing so Marie you just released your
first kids book what is Kiki and Jax
about what do you I don't know what the
morning fight thing up there when you
know what they put the whole nun days so
actually created this book because I
wanted to kind of convey the the joy of
tidying up to the younger generation
they study the usual coming take a story
not good and it's not just an
instructional book that teaches kids
this is how you tidy it's actually a
story a narrative about how the twos
friendship is kind of based on this idea
of tidying okay I'm gonna take that home
to my children all of them even the
teenagers Murray's new children's book
Kiki and Jax's out now I'm obsessed with
Marie Kondo and the spark joy de
cluttering extravaganza that has taken
over American case you don't know her
like she literally you you you pick
things right in your hand and you make
sure that they spark joy to you she has
the whole thing look I've read the book
I've highlighted I've done every room in
my house with the garage and it's now
this like you mean better sanctuary I
feel clearer I have more time it's
amazing I have like full-blown Marie
Kondo leg
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I've met so many like actresses and
celebrities I love but like you're my
favorite ever okay Marie this is Beth
and I swear she one arm you know
anything you would want to say to Marie
we that's what we had you here we were
like you got to have questions no just
thank you so much it's it's you say in
your book and it's so true that it goes
beyond decluttering like it really
changes your whole life and I've had so
much like people walk into my house and
be like there's just a different energy
in here like it just feels better and I
feel better and everybody should do it
[Applause]
method on our whole house we have some
photos let's see them look at those
piles obviously that was the closet yeah
amongst all the bings okay okay it's
getting better getting better
I fold I roll like that so I have it a
tiny closet but that's the most room
I've ever had in it and I'm very proud
accident all right well that's do you
have any more questions for me like you
said you have a tiny closet is there
anything yes so I have a tiny closet and
I got rid of anything that didn't spark
joy but then I got some new clothes that
did spark joy cluttered and anybody I
know chicory oh boy Erica today we mark
rules it then talk some of the
guided-missile so just understanding the
folding process very thoroughly that
really kind of saves a lot of space
inside your closet I didn't even think
about that like folding it yeah and like
shelves like that wait well aren't we
about to learn how to fold it properly
right let's see if I thought me got the
old wooden oven I think so
okay you get the Kelly Clark I have a
lot of problems with late like I always
do it upside down where you can't see
the t-shirt like I don't I forget how to
do it the way your side works a bit in
apparel so you can usually see my yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so if you want to show the logo
just make sure when you start it's on
the outside its facing you oh so wait
this is wrong this is wrong you
shouldn't do this they do that's no cool
that's Tyler make sure you pour in some
love as you do this okay wait you do
what make sure you do it with love a
little skinny and then take the top and
bring it pull it towards okay oh look
your smiley facing there just I like it
I like your spark of joy so what's a
[ __ ] what's next for you marine I heard
you're expanding your e-commerce shop
right no no mr. ah I know what this look
Jimmy come on let's make up let me say
yes so actually I made an e-commerce
shop that is full of only things that
spark joy for me well thank you so much
now Oh yours are standing perfectly
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this